so this message is specifically
dedicated to those of you that work for
Commission's or you're an entrepreneur
salesperson meaning you don't get a
salary you don't get hourly nothing you
work you make money you don't you don't
make money look I'm gonna tell you bout
a time when I first got involved in
sales and I got my first Commission
check when I left my job and I got my
first Commission check I made fifteen
hundred dollars in a day and I came home
and I sat then grabbed the paper and I
started doing the math and I said wait a
minute if I repeated this behavior ten
times I would have made $15,000 in a
month if I did a hundred times I would
have made $150,000 in my 1.8 million
dollar year income over ten year period
18 million dollars that's crazy and it's
doable I can't do that a hundred times a
month I will never forget that moment
because i sat there and I ask the most
important question here's a question are
you willing to do it are you willing to
repeat this behavior to make that kind
of money then it went to the most
important question to ask yourself what
you do it privately with nobody else
around you know what that question is is
it worth it that's what you asked is it
worth it because is it worth me missing
out on all these parties all these
birthday parties all these gatherings
all these days of going to movies to the
pool you know bar you know - but
billiards and all this whatever it is
that you do that's purely a form of
entertainment - I really want to put my
head down and get to work like that I
don't know if I do is it worth it that
moment nobody knows that conversation
what you tell yourself it's only you
versus you no one is around you no one
is around you to tell you go get him
because deep down inside you have said I
don't think it's worth it I'm not gonna
pay the prices out like that I don't
want to go that hardcore to get it
because the reality is here's the
reality of it I've told this to myself
and so many people over and over again
if you can make fifteen hundred dollars
in a day you can make two thousand
dollars in a day if you can make two
thousand you can make four thousand if
you can make four thousand you can make
eight thousand if you make eight
thousand you can make sixteen thousand
dollars in a day if you can make sixteen
you can make thirty-two so what's the
limit the only limit that you have is
you asking yourself if it's worth it to
get to the next level your identity on
how you view yourself and last one is
quietly how
long you can last your stamina your
endurance your energy while nobody else
is watching you nobody else is watching
you this is holiday season this is the
most casual time of the year everybody's
chilling hanging out relaxing watching
movies typically they leave work at 5
o'clock they leave at 3:30 typically
maybe the sales guys go at 9 o'clock or
8 o'clock they leave at 6 o'clock and
say I got some personal appointments to
run where you just go on home relaxing
because you want to have dinner on all
this other stuff this is the season
where you get tested because had one of
my good guys I mentored for a while they
said Pat we're gonna be so big in the
industry they're making like $50,000 at
that time we're gonna do so we're gonna
make millions per year
I said let's see how you behave when you
make a quarter million then they made a
quarter million then it's a pat we told
you were gonna keep going I said let's
see if you're gonna get to half a
million and see how you behave then I
went to half a million and they were
making 40 $50,000 a month I said we
could get to 3/4 of a million
then he got to 3/4 of a million the
Lambos the house the parties to travel
the accolades the clothes you know all
this stuff to shin helped everything
there then it gets upon when you realize
do you really want to do the work to get
to seven figures Multi seven figures ten
million or eight figures nine do you
want to get to that level or is a level
at a point that you hit that you slow
down because if you hit a level and you
slow down what you're really telling the
world is this entire time was only all
about money it wasn't all about you
finding out your best it wasn't all
about you finding out if you want to
find out your true potential one day do
you really see in a background the song
that's playing maybe you don't hear this
all I need is one mic I need one mic by
NAS all I need is one mic you have the
mic if you made $1,500 in a day you have
the mic what are you gonna do with this
mic to go to 15k hundred 50k what are
you gonna do there's a big difference in
a lifestyle of making fifteen hundred
dollars per month versus fifteen
thousand dollars per month versus a
hundred fifty thousand dollars per month
it's a different lifestyle it's a
complete different lifestyle but it's
not based on talent you could pull it
off if it matters to you and you answer
the question is it worth it you will do
it but internally if you told yourself
it's now worth it
don't be surprised it ain't gonna happen
for you I hope when you ask that
question from yourself is it worth it
behind closed doors when nobody else is
around I hope you give the right answer
to yourself not just to save them
because 2020 is gonna be a very big year
for a lot of people that are planning on
having a big year I hope you're fully
prepared to have a killer 2020 better
than the last 10 years combined I hope
you have that kind of plan for yourself
and if you do you need to know mindset
going into 2020 Merry Christmas
everybody
much love bye-bye